The Dip
Seth Godin is such a talented writer...
...that several of his books could have ended up on here.
I picked this one because it's incredibly short...
...and yet it was incredibly impactful for me in my career.
"Quitting" for me has always been an ugly word.
I usually stick with things until the bitter end,...
...but this book really showed me that knowing when to quit...
...can be an incredible skill.
As he said it: "Quit or be exceptional.
Average is for losers."
I listened to this while driving through the Oregon countryside...
...at the very beginning of this year,...
...wondering if posting these videos online was going to work out for me.
All I can say is: "Seth, you're the man."